as proof I want to show you some gold
tips and techniques a lot of times when
students first learn about proving
triangles congruent or even working with
geometry proofs in general it's a little
bit intimidating so let me show you my
process the first thing that I do is I
look at the Givens okay and I think of
the Givens as clues or hints the other
thing that I like to do is I like to
mark the diagram with what I can figure
out from the Givens so let's go ahead
and start there we have a B is congruent
to DC so a B is congruent to DC you can
see that I'm marking that on the diagram
now that might be a clue I might be able
to figure out something more from that
if I can I want to make it as a step in
my two column proof but this is pretty
much there's not much we can do with
that we can just say okay we know
they're congruent let's mark the diagram
so we have to remember that we can just
visually see it on the diagram the
second given is that a B is parallel to
DC so they're saying that this line and
this line are parallel so I like to just
draw a little arrow to show that those
are two sides are parallel the other
thing I like to do when lines are
parallel is I like to extend those lines
a little bit like this and then this is
like a transversal you can extend that a
little bit further so what should kind
of jump out at you now is this diagram
here that you learned about earlier in
geometry two parallel lines cut by a
transversal now that's a clue what can
we figure out from that well we know
that this angle and this angle are
congruent by alternate interior angles
so these two angles are gonna be the
same and so we're gonna then put that as
a step in our proof so first things
first though let's go ahead and write
the the Givens down usually that's the
first thing that students like to do
just to get it out of the way
a B is congruent to DC and we also know
that a B is parallel to DC and we're
just gonna say given okay now for step
number two we're gonna say that these
two angles are congruent so that's angle
abd angle abd this congruent angle C D B
now remember when you're right angles
you want to make sure that you make that
vertex the middle ladder the other
mistake you don't want to make is you
don't want to just call this angle B
because somebody might think you're
talking about this angle this angle the
whole angle whenever it's ambiguous like
that you want to use three points making
sure that that middle letter is the
vertex or the hint
so this was my alternate interior angles
I'm just going to abbreviate step number
three now is we really can't figure
anything else out from the Givens we
tried that okay
so now I go to the diagram and I try to
figure out is there anything on the
diagram that I can show this congruent
well you can see that this side here me
D is shared between these two triangles
okay because you can see they're right
next to each other they're sharing that
side it's going to be the same length in
both triangles so we can say that V D
segment BD is congruent to segment BD
and that is the reflexive property it's
just like looking in a mirror or the
same height in the mirror as you are in
real life and again I like to when I
figure things out I like to mark it on
the diagram so I don't have to remember
that I can just visually see so now we
want to prove that triangles congruent
you can see that we have side angle side
the angle in between the two sides they
call that the included angle is
congruent over in this triangle see side
angle side that angle is in between the
two sides that we know are congruent to
the these two sides so essentially what
you can see is if we pick up this
triangle rotated 180 degrees the sides
are gonna match up the included angle is
gonna match up and we have these
side-angle-side congruence so basically
we know that the triangles are congruent
by side angle side and whatever you're
trying to prove this is always going to
be the last step in your proof so
triangle abd is congruent to triangle C
D B and you've got it if you want to see
more examples of working with two column
proofs I'll have a playlist right there
you can check out for more help with
this and if you're new to the channel
subscribe I look forward to helping you
in the future videos and I'll talk to
you soon